hey you use code al-mar'u in the
fortnight's shop hello and welcome to
Playstation grenade it's time to bust
out some myths once again and this time
it's all about the brand-new item in the
world of fortnight's the proximity mines
[Music]
so how does the proximity mind work well
it's super simple when an enemy gets too
close the mind springs up and explodes
things to note right away proximity
mines cannot be crouched underneath and
activate at just under a tiles distance
away
hitting 450 damage those are the basics
so let's test it and break it with some
myths we'll start small can jumping in a
hiding spot block mine damage hmm the
only way to find out is to try it we
place down a proximity mind next to a
haystack and attempted to jump in and
no the jump animation is too slow to
block the incoming damage here's the
test again with a dumpster dive no
success next myth another easy one
proximity mine to float on water well
see for yourself this is what happens
when a proximity mine hits h2o
instant trigger myth busted but hang on
a moment this got me thinking can a
proximity mine be used to catch fish
maybe it's got to write well here we go
and oh yes it's perfect
instant fishing and a little safer than
firing a rocket or wasting your time
with a fishing rod our next myth please
enemy proximity mines trigger friendly
mines another super easy one to test
first my enemy threw down a mine and
kept a safe distance back then I did the
same and nope they don't interfere with
each other at all but of course where
the myth chases we can take this further
should our foe walk towards the mines
what will happen when triggered by the
way that one is a friendly mine and this
one is an enemy mine
okay so the science here minds can stack
damage both friendly and enemy versions
but only after being triggered
interesting stuff I have an idea let's
take this myth to the next level
proximity mines will activate c4 oh yes
we're gonna do this we are becoming a
Michael Bay film today here's the setup
this vehicle is the bomb
quite literally it's full of c4 but
today we won't be using the detonator
instead I'll place down a proximity mine
of course we hide where we put the
proximity mine in a real game because it
sticks out like a sore thumb but for the
test version here is fine so we need a
crash test dummy and here he is this is
teased by the way he's one of many
people that gives me a hand from our
discard you should totally join anyway I
asked him to run past this vehicle and
here's what happened holy heck that's
brilliant self activating bombs it's
like Call of Duty all over again and
dying on those trip mines repeatedly one
more time for posterity
the proximity mine hits 450 but every
single c4 after that hit something
strength to bloody magical ok we're on a
roll now next myth mines stick to boxes
a nice and easy one let's quickly test
it as we throw the mine it attempts to
bounce away like its hit a person but
then vanishes completely well in
actuality it's inside the box look stuck
to the person inside as long as they are
friendly of course they can now walk
around openly but here's the test will
the mine trigger when next to an enemy
Metal Gear Solid style
[Music]
yep works great and doesn't hurt the guy
inside to result but of course that's
only 50 damage is there possibly
something else we could do
sure is give me a sec a quick point to
note here is that depending on how well
you throw the mine results on how
clearly everyone else can see the thing
when you're moving around oh and also
should they leave the box the mines
aren't guaranteed to stick around
sometimes despawning and sometimes
detaching completely but now it's time
for the ultimate myth proximity mine
plus C 4 equals eliminations let's test
this out first we threw on a proximity
mine and followed it up with a c4 block
or two the question is will this
activate near an enemy so let's try it
[Music]
hell yeah the ultimate box fight I
cannot wait to see this in daily YouTube
click beta videos they will go to town
on this one this strat is the reason for
tonight is great again so have fun with
it guys I know I will okay let's go back
to basics proximity mines can be stacked
an easy one yet again let's stack the
mines oh oh I did not expect that who'd
have thunk it
proximity mines will actively bounce
when in contact with each other so I
won't lie for the next 30 minutes we
attempted to bounce multiple proximity
mines around the world it became like a
skimming stone session like a minigame
here's our best attempt Oh so let's turn
it over to you
can you beat for skipping stones in a
row please make a video upload it to
youtube and the one with the most skips
will be featured in the next episode of
myth chasers remember to DM a video link
to me on twitter i'm adam grenade over
there okay back to the myths royal
vendetta says you can stick a mine
to a rocket or rocket riding a mine
basically well let's try it
timing this one was a little tricky but
second try this happened
what the hell is that in slow-mo we can
see more as the rocket and mine hit the
same place the mine sticks to that point
rather than the rocket itself giving us
a floating mine until the rocket
explodes this sees all kinds of weird
isn't it next myth can a mine be hidden
under a cone a good myth nice and simple
I threw down a cone under mine and asked
a member of my squad to hide alongside
it could they sit under here and heal
without being disturbed this could be a
strapless see what happens then when the
enemy arrived and tried to take out the
Kong this happens the trap activated
yeah it's only 50 damage but we could
hide c4 under there too now we know that
c4 is set off by procs mines next myth
proximity mine damage can be blocked by
other players hmm this is an interesting
one can we take less damage by standing
behind another player in the blast
radius well let's try it we have us
lined up we knew the first person would
take 50 damage but what about the two
stood behind here's the test in action
sadly mythbusted everyone takes 50
damage regardless of who is in front of
them as long as they're in the blast
radius so we had a bunch of myths ready
to go for the boats but sadly proximity
mines won't stay attached to boats rip
the dream at first I thought this was
due to the water but nope it's the boat
they've been deliberately made to repel
mines got it
okay let's crack on we haven't been to
steamy stacks this episode yet here's
the myth a mine will float at steamy
stacks mono is expecting so much from
this myth but then I got there and tried
it what do you think happens yeah it
sticks to the Kevin juice just like c4
does just like grenades do dummy this
could have been epic oh my god next myth
decoys trigger proximity mines
this one looks promising my enemy threw
down a mine and then this happened when
a decoy landed close by success but due
to the decoy landing so close I decided
to test it again this time my clone did
well she just ran away
you must take after me anyway here's a
tent number 3
and yes indeed decoys do activate
proximity mines and take themselves out
why don't we try a myth with one of
those telephone boxes it's possible to
place a proximity mine inside the
disguised booth I love this and this is
what happened throw it straight at the
front door and the mine will jump inside
and instantly activate teammates can't
trigger the bomb but what about enemies
are you ready for this epic huh I'm not
does nothing the mine is deactivated in
the phone box and eventually Dee spawns
that has so much potential I really
thought we'd got something then but no
we can't kill people inside the
telephone boxes okay we have one last
place to test proximity mines using
those air drops in the sky
check out this myth it's possible to
hide a proximity mine underneath a
Supply Drop this one may be my favorite
here's the test as the drop is slowly
falling we place a mine in the drop zone
and check it out it worked completely
hidden away while almost completely and
then next we asked an enemy to get close
enough to trigger the mine would it work
it sure does how good is that for
science we tested this again but this
time we shot down the balloon to see if
it would still work with the force of it
falling on top of it and yes it does
it's bloody brilliant but there's still
the issue of only taking 50 damage hmm
we're not gonna get many people with
that so remember the c4 here is the
ultimate test to end this video c4 plus
proximity mine plus the underside of a
Supply Drop equals well see for yourself
[Music]
how satisfying was that if you stayed
until the end please know that I
appreciate you being here for so long
and if you used coda tomorrow in the
shop like these guys this week legends
on screen you are responsible for this
series being here I hope you enjoy it
thank you so much I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]